Brittany is in West Palm Beach Florida
hi Brittany how are you better than I
deserve
Merry Christmas how can I help yes you
yes so my husband got ourselves a little
bit of pickle with her money in credit
card debt and we're kind of trying to
get on the same page with payoffs that's
it but he's not really he said he's on
the same page but it's just not working
very well we're actually not doing that
you want him to do well I'm working
really hard to see not doing that you
want him to do just being on the same
page just me really what's that mean not
on the same page what's that mean he
doesn't want to sell anything he doesn't
want to sell any of his stuff he wants
to keep his truck that he barely uses
when I think we should kill it and it's
just a constant height right and so you
saw his truck okay what's his truck
worth eight thousand and it's a third
it's a third vehicle it's our second
vehicle but he has a work ban that he
can use
oh I see okay and and one of yours one
of yours are we selling I'm just trying
to sell every other little thing I have
because my car is completely and are you
guys are you doing a budget together
yeah we're trying to but it just seems
like he doesn't understand that we just
don't have the money that he thinks we
have it just I don't know how to get it
through wait a minute if he sits down
and looks at your income and you're both
agreeing that this is our income and
then you have the items on there that
you both know agree you need to pay what
does he not understand he believes that
if he is working overtime like he is now
he should be able to buy those certain
things he has not looked at the budget
and understood the budget then because
that's a childish statement by someone
who's trying to ignore facts that are
mathematical facts so what we're saying
is he still want you to be his mommy I
know and he tells
all the time he doesn't need me to be
but yeah he needs to sit down and be the
man and sit with his wife the woman and
look at the budget and say we are in
we're grown-ups we're not in Congress we
have to live on less than we make we
have to put together a plan here and I
want him to actually grasp these numbers
and you need to help him make that very
important so honey out of because here's
the thing he's going to come to the
conclusion sell his truck once he
understands what the numbers are he's
going to come to the conclusion of these
other things once he gets agreed
agreement on this but right now he's
still standing on the sidelines throwing
rocks at you right everything you've
told me is about you trying to get him
to do something that he didn't have any
investment in understanding why we need
to do it when he sits down actually
grasps the numbers it changes everything
I'll give you a microcosm of that okay
one of the biggest fights
Sharon Ramsey and I ever had we were
about 27 or 28 years old we were
starting to solve our first budgets and
she wanted to spend $500 on groceries
and I went ballistic we had three kids
and this was 1980 something and I went
nuts and she went nuts back at me and
you have no idea you've never even set
your butt in a grocery store you don't
know what stuff costs and you have no
idea and I'm like well that's just
absolutely freaking ridiculous she says
okay big boy come to the grocery store
and let's look at the real numbers so I
said I'll prove you wrong and I went to
the grocery store and I'll walk down the
aisles and she was right I lost because
she was dealing with facts but when I
got involved enough to not argue
concepts and I looked at the facts then
we could come to a meeting of the minds
and that's what you got to get with him
you're gonna have to get it get your arm
around his neck and and put the
chokehold on him until he understands
that he has to look at these numbers
with you and do that and make him do the
budget you sit down through the budget
I'm gonna Center with you you do the
budget like she made me go to the
grocery store I went because I was mad
and I was gonna prove her wrong
well you think you don't need to sell
your truck sit down here and do a budget
you show me why I'm wrong